marin morris hi
hi honey look at you looking radiant
tonight in that plunging gown
omg thank you looking like a hot
mama how's date night been for you and
ryan i think it's been fairly successful
we got to perform together um check
and won two acm awards so
it's been a pretty banging night vegan
sunday night
i'd say so just a typical sunday fun day
for you and ryan right
yeah well it's about to get more fun i'm
about to go drink so
that after your performance was he
nerves or was he good what was he like
after the performance
he was a little nervous but you know he
was he was a champ
he he handled it well we were so happy
with how it turned out
so we're really over the moon female
artist of the year
and song of the year yeah you said the
bones has taken on
it was a journey for the bones the song
you wrote it you wrote it whenever you
and ryan were dating is that correct
yeah so it's it's a bit of an older song
um
for me in my life but it has taken on
such depth over the years it's sort of
like a fine wine it's like aged
in meaning and in sound and so um yeah
that kind of hit me
tonight on stage just accepting the
award for song of the year because
it's just crazy when your songs
sometimes know you better than you know
them
and this song definitely knew me in a
deeper way
even three four years ago when i wrote
it um than i did
then so i am yeah it's just it's crazy
that songs end up having a mind of their
own
it's had meaning for so many people as
well i know even whenever i listen to it
with my fiance we're like
oh we it resonates with us too but for
you it's taken on from dating ryan
to marrying ryan to having a baby with
ryan and the bones girl they seem to be
real good in that household
oh man that's like a double entendre i
guess
i didn't even think about that i meant
like the foundation
girlfriend okay well both are good
i am blushing on a whole new level i
would say that you
carly and kelsey have a lot to celebrate
tonight you said the bones is like fine
wine
but so is your friendship the you three
gals have a lot to celebrate tonight as
well
oh my gosh yes carly walking away with
two
kelsey had an amazing performance with
kenny and
you know just all i think this is the
first time the three of us
have been in the same category for
female artists
so that was really special and you know
and ashley as well
and miranda is just we all i would say
like confidently
killed it this year in a year where we
couldn't play shows
and to all have each other's backs and
do what we do
and we're all so musically diverse like
when none of us sound like the other
girl
um we're just doing what we do which is
music and
in country music and so i think that um
to be
recognized in this way with women that
inspire me as a songwriter
is a huge compliment and i hope that
they're all celebrating tonight because
they turned in a banner year of work
and i'm a huge fan of all of theirs it's
been like such a girl power night we
love it so much
you